around these two I always work up if I
hadn't ever divide a nickel for every
time you've said them I'd have a full
cup
but it'll be a Dixie cup with my dicks
[Music]
my first impression of them was they
were also very funny and kind well Dave
does the impressions I do the impression
I am gonna die swag I'm gonna poke your
right knee I bought I was nine years old
so I knew who John Stamos was because my
sisters were in love with him
just about everything I wore I wanted to
wear at the time although now I can look
back and think that was not a good
choice luckily I was little enough that
I have like possible deniability that I
was not in charge of making those
choices me Gibbler had the most
atrocious wardrobe ever I have to say
those high-waisted jeans I don't know I
I don't know what I was thinking I don't
know why I thought they looked good we
were dresses one time and we liked that
we part of the shoe oh yeah that was
just we won't have the show I know here
at my home yeah that's perfect
my hair is not naturally curly so I
spent a lot of nights sleeping in those
terrible sponge rollers looking back
maybe we should give in her own a
simpler hairdo everybody wondered how
did these three guys that knew nothing
about raising girls or doing hair
managed to get her hair looking like
that every day Danny always stayed in
his own bedroom on the second floor then
eventually we turned the basement into
Joey's room attic became a recording
studio jesse DJ got her own room which
was I think Michelle's room which is
weird because we had an extra room with
Jesse there's an extra room there
why didn't Stephanie DJ and Michelle all
get their own
after Jessi moved into the Attic huh
interesting
yeah I mean I had cousins that were
twins so I could tell them apart which
makes total sense
you know the Saget's and the Olsen's
very similar I think Ashley has a mole
that mary-kate doesn't
I wouldn't know them almost by the back
of their head I can tell who was who
just by mannerisms and stuff like that I
just wish they would wear nametags all
the time I could never tell them apart
ever I still can't tell them apart when
they announced that they were bringing
back fuller house and the fan reaction
to that was the first time where I was
like oh wow like this show means a lot
to a lot of people going home I go let's
celebrate let's go to a strip club loser
and it was like and we're like no
alcohol though there was no okay they
were very but you tee this up you tee
this up with you knew somebody was very
quiet I said I know the guys they'll let
us in would be very no one over there
walk in sneaky and we sit down hey Bob
Saget did cool a sweetened and I went
into the bathroom to take a break and
while we were in the stalls some fans
followed us in there and we're passing
pads of paper and pens underneath the
stall to ask for our autograph so I
thought wow we're really famous now the
only review I read was the show oh is
that this show won't last you
Thanksgiving and that we were a three
men and a baby ripoff
they love gum and they were too little
to chew gum so if you were chewing gum
they always would stop and try to pry
your mouth open and they say what having
what having and that or that whenever
they were got gum got gum what having
was so funny there was a time when like
mary-kate didn't want to do a scene and
she or like her hands I think had peanut
butter all over them and she was just
like I don't know I want to wash my
hands I want to wash my hands I'm gonna
sing I'm gonna sing if I don't wash my
hands and like didn't want to do the
scene and it was the cutest thing ever
when they wanted to stop working they
were just like I'm done I'm done I'm
gonna sing if you make me stay here I'm
done then for like okay I guess that's a
wrap
if I did have a crush on anyone it's
probably Scott winder although we are
closer friends than boyfriend-girlfriend
like you make you Ruby he showed us his
boobs he will always ask if like oh you
think John was so cute oh he's like my
family you married one no girl to play
Michelle oh yeah I just remember I'm
gonna say I had a crush drovers in love
with anyone it's gonna be common I never
wanted to say oh my G OD on the show so
I used to just say my personal life oh
mylanta so I think a babysitter of mine
would say that all the time and I just
loved it so I just asked the writers so
I could say that instead and it became a
thing
the cast rated the set so thoroughly
that by the time I thought oh I should
take something there was nothing like
some thanks guys I took mr. woodchuck
puppet yeah my face still have him my
dog ate his face
I took my pillow person which is no
longer around it was very sad my dog
chewed it up one day so I didn't take
one souvenir because John Stamos took
them all he took like the ceramic duck
that was in the kitchen bunnies I have
cow shadow
I had the sign from wake up San
Francisco there was a pig like a plush
pig that I think he took as well
we went on a date we went to Disney on
us she says it wasn't a date or
something and I say when you make out on
Matterhorn thanks right were you making
out with her or somebody else I said why
do you tell people we made out on the
Matterhorn he goes cuz it sounds funny
and I think the real truth is is we're
too old to remember never thought it in
my life and so happy I get to you know
over time and we realized how incredibly
successful the show is but I don't think
we ever thought you know ten years ago
that we would be coming back and doing
this and now look at the bringing back
all these old shows when the Gilmore
Girls - willing graces it's we've
certainly started a trend we are a fun
group even coming back and doing this
incarnation of the show there's still I
mean look at him you know we just if you
turn to look at someone that for 30
years and it's they're there and they're
Joey I absolutely knew that full house
would turn into four house just like I
know that fuller house will become
fullest house in 20 years from now are
we up to 30 seconds of usable material
yet
[Music]